but he wasn't really all bad I think he
just craved a little affection it's the
dress that elevated Marilyn Monroe from
movie star to American icon it's a very
interesting point of view
[Music]
the white halter dress blown up words
well Monroe stood on a subway grate in
1955 7-year itch is perhaps her most
memorable costume the go-to choice for
Monroe impersonators and immortalized in
a 26 foot tall statue of the Hollywood
star now one of two versions of the
dress is going up for auction there are
two white dresses we sold the original
screen use Debbie Reynolds dress for 5.7
million dollars many years ago William
trivia made that dress William trivia
also made this dress so after the movie
was over trivia asked Debbie if he could
borrow her dress to make a copy for
himself because he didn't have a copy
and he uses to dress me exhibited around
the world his whole life the dress is
just one piece of Monroe memorabilia
that's on display in Beverly Hills
before being put up for bid in October
by auction house profiles in history
miss Marilyn Monroe and you can go
anywhere in the world and she gets more
and more popular so I think that people
just want a piece of that
also up for auction Monroe's showgirl
costume from Gentlemen Prefer Blondes
they just don't make things like this
anymore these were all handmade hand
beaded made by William trivia I mean
just exquisite and it's amazing that
they survived as well as a photograph
that seems to solve a Monroe mystery
this picture of the actress alongside
20th Century Fox executive Ben lion it's
signed by Munro whose real name was
Norma Jeane Mortenson with the
inscription dear Ben you found me named
me and believed in me when no one else
did Ben Lyon was one of her closest
friends and the legend is she went to
Malibu and Ben said who do you think
your father was and the legend is she
said well I think his last name was
Munro and he's like that's a good name
well the letter answers questions the
white halter dress will be the item
attracting bidders for reference the
dress Monroe wore when she sang happy
birthday to President John F Kennedy
sold for 4.8 million dollars two years
ago a price nearly double what the
auction house expected and what will it
cost to own this piece of Hollywood
history you know with Marilyn Monroe
it's really hard to predict because it's
you know the fan bases all over the
world I mean it could sell for two or
three hundred thousand dollars Elaine we
can pull our resources can afford it
maybe Anthony can step in for us I love
the fact that we know the story about
her name Wow that was a big question how
did she get her name yeah we're in
popularity
yeah very powerful it keeps building
yeah